[Music]
on the Big Bang I don't know how much in
advance they come to when they want you
to do something a little embarrassed
very little very little mysterious you
know spring it on you if they want your
character no no they're not mean and
look they've done things before that
I've been liking they want me to wear
the Princess Leia slave bikini and I
said okay thank you
ya know and they talked it down we can
Hawk together I got a French maid's
uniform instead okay which was I
considered a real deal not the situation
I had no I didn't want you to see my
situation right so I talked down from
there but no I frequently it's just when
the script arrives day before rehearsal
starts you'll find out right for example
they had you you have seen with Mayim
Bialik yeah where well maybe you should
tell her that spanking was involved oh
yes well okay look yeah she wants
physical attention from Sheldon that
he's not giving so he/she has to loop
him in two ways to give it to her and so
she behaves badly and his didactic
personality is well you must be punished
you know so he he asked a spanker and it
was in one episode where she had
pretended to be sick and had lied to him
and he said well you have to be punished
and I think you need a spanking and and
this was something that we were working
on all week that was going to happen
off-camera it was gonna be more of a you
know I got a noise thing that happened
and and she and they would the oh my you
know you could just say the viewer would
imagine the viewer would imagine it the
VSO that's how are you hurt Zoe the
night of the taping we get to that final
scene and they start saying it's gonna
be on camera which I'm I'm fine with I
don't mind spanking somebody but I can't
tell you how hard it was to when you're
concentrating on making the noise all
week it's like doing a radio play once
the camera was on me and I realize I
haven't I haven't worked at all on what
my face or the rest of my I don't know
how to handle myself during this so I
was getting frustrated and we kept
having you take after take because I
kept I kept laughing which was kind of
rare for me but as one of the scene you
know how some of them you get angry and
people laugh at you and it makes you
more angry take me seriously but I was
kind of doing to myself that I was so
angry but I kept laughing and then I'd
be really angry when have to cut and the
whole time you have to be spanking my
Alec yeah she has bent over me on this
couch tape after tape being whupped yeah
were you worried about hurting her that
it you know well not for a while it was
several takes in before you finally
click and go she's a person you know
I said are you okay and she said I am
okay I I said are you positive and she
say and she never showed me her bare ass
cheek I don't know if there was a bruise
or not but she assured me that she was
fine mm-hmm
thank you my um was it did you find that
you have a certain technique well you
have to because you know I mean the
important thing on camera off with the
spank is it's the noise you know it
really is and if you get a you I can
demo
[Applause]
you're a good man
this is he has a good but for this to be
honest with you there's a there's a
thing going on here okay so you want to
make sure you get the full hand I'm
sorry if it hurts but biome can handle
it
no worries it'll be worse you know why I
have we want to hear it what do you I
honestly don't know if that was a good
one it didn't sound loud enough to me
right one two three
[Applause]
I have no but whatsoever I got great for
spanking either yeah well I'm one tendon
the dry ones right down right you would
just hear hips hip bone cracking and if
it hurts it's not funny
exactly